alo Đợi tí xem
setting Ok setting có vẻ x MX rồi
à Xin chào các
thì trước khi vào những cái thứ sẽ chia
sẻ hôm nay các bạn thấy là danh sách sẽ
chia sẻ có vẻ khá rất là dài ấy đúng
không ạ
Ừ mình định tâm sự kiểu thường thì mình
vẫn sẽ định tâm sự một đôi chút đúng
không
ạ tôi thực ra đôi khi tôi không nhớ được
chính xác mấy cái link này là gì đâu Em
có bao giờ nghĩ Đế có những con người
còn không được Đợi đợi t tiếng hơi to
là nó g ý cái bên cạnh cái thứ thử
này cận thận bản quyền á
ồ cái này không biết bị dính hay không
Bởi vì cái này từ tiktok mà đúng không
Cứ thử phát chắc không đâu 1
bình tĩnh bình tĩnh các bạn nghe được
tiếng của máy không
nhỉ Hình như là không mà đúng
không tiếng của cái này hình như là
tiếng đấy từ từ mic của tôi ra chứ không
phải là từ từ máy đúng
là có thêm vụ sao mà
được ok ok đấy các bạn xem thử cái này
xong
rồi mình tâm sự nhá Em có bao giờ nghĩ
đến có những con người còn không được sự
lựa chọn họ còn không được vào Sài Gòn
họ còn không có đủ cái cơ hội để vào Sài
Gòn họ còn không có sự lựa chọn nào khác
phải chấp nhận một cuộc sống nào đấy mà
họ không có sự thay đổi không có được
nổi một cái sự lựa chọn rằng là ngày mai
họ có được nghỉ nếu như họ bị ốm hay
không chứ chưa nói gì to tát hơn nếu như
ngày mai họ chỉ cần không ra đường không
làm cái công việc của họ cực kỳ chán nản
thì họ còn không có tiền ăn chưa Không
có tiền mua một miếng bánh để họ á m em
bao giờ nghĩ những người đấy không có
những người như thế trong cuộc sống có
những người như thế và không phải là bởi
vì họ kém đâu Em không phải là bởi vì họ
rốt đâu em họ rốt họ kém họ không thông
minh họ không các thứ bởi vì họ không có
điều kiện để làm bất kỳ một cái gì khác
cả đ là sự thật em có bao giờ nghĩ người
ta bảo nhìn lên thì không bằng ai nhìn
xuống thì mình hơn rất là nhiều người
cái câu này ai cũng biết nhưng mà đôi
khi chúng ta quên đi Vậy thì đề quan
trọng tích cực là em phải tự nhìn về
hướng th cực không ai giúp em được em
phải tự nhìn được rằng là gì em cố gắng
thì bản thân em so với lại em so với lại
em cách đây 1 năm hai năm em có khá hơn
không em Có tốt hơn
Ờ cái video này của anh pi
piu pi piu cũng kiểu là một trong những
thần tượng của tôi thần tượng ở đây
không phải là tôi xem tất cả mọi video
anh đấy thực là không có đủ thời gian
ngồi xem livestream anh đấy rất là nhiều
nhưng mà
ừ kiểu dạng là trong các streamer Hoặc
là các vlogger các thứ thì chỉ có JV
evermine là cả p piu không nhớ còn thêm
mai nữa không thì là những người
mà kiểu ảnh hưởng đến không phải hành
hẳn ảnh hưởng nhưng mà đại khá tôi khá
khẩm phục JV evermine chắc ảnh hưởng khá
nhiều trong cách nói chuyện để tôi được
nói chuyện như bây giờ
ờ ừ có tôi xem một vài cái video cắt của
à Vài video ngắn của anh độ nữa kiểu
được cắt ra ấy cũng khá là hợp Ờ nhưng
mà tôi không xem livestream của anh đấy
lắm nhưng mà ừ những người đấy họ được
như họ thành công được như bây giờ thì
chắc chắn là do cái tư tưởng cái lối suy
nghĩ của họ nó nó mình làm streamer mà
nên là mình sẽ phải phù hợp với số đông
đúng không ạ gọi là mình cũng phải đúng
tương đi mình phải khá là kiểu suy nghĩ
phải đúng đắn thì mới kiểu dạng có nh
nhiều người nghe đúng không
ạ thì cái tư tưởng đấy Cái tư tưởng vừa
rồi của anh đấy nói thì thực ra tôi chưa
chưa Cái h hôm nay tôi mới mới được nghe
cái đấy Và tôi thấy khá giống tôi thường
hay nhắn ngủ với các bạn về việc là là
chúng ta không so sánh mình với ai cả
màt Hường hay so sánh mình với quá khứ
và mình à Ừ mình chỉ biết mình đôi khi
mình phải nghĩ ch bạn bản thân thôi mình
phấn đấu vì bản thân chứ mình không phải
phấn đấu vì bất kỳ ai cả không phải vì
bố mẹ bảo thế hay là thầy cô bảo thế
Không ai cầm tay chỉ lối kiểu quyết định
hộ mình cả tự mình quyết định thì thành
công hay thất bại vẫn là do mình đúng
không ạ
à Có thể có thể kiểu do số phận đưa đẩy
vân vân vân gì đó nhưng mà mình không ba
giờ mình à Nên a kiểu Ừ thì vì tao sinh
ra như thế nên thôi Tao chấp nhận là như
thế thì đúng không
ạ Nói chung là tôi thì tôi quan điểm là
mình luôn cầu tiến mình luôn cố gắng hơn
ừ nhắc lế cái cầu tiến tự nhiên tôi lại
nhớ quả chuyện manga này ờ ừ thì nếu mà
giả sử Giả sử ông biết được
à biết được là tương lai mình sẽ thế nào
giống như là Nobita mấy ông ở đây tất cả
đểu chắc kiểu gì đểu đ Đọc Doraemon rồi
đúng không ạ
Ờ giống như Nobita Nobita mà nghe được
tương lai của mình kiểu Nếu mà tiếp tục
sống cuộc sống như này tương lai nó sẽ
thế nào đúng không ạ Tôi không nói tương
lai xấu hay đẹp về cơ bản thì tôi nghe
phân tích của chán chê nhiều đặc biệt là
trên nhóm v v voer nhóm V chia sẻ
phim tôi Tôi không thể đọc đầy đủ tên
của nó ở đây được khá tục đại khái thì
ờ
trên đấy thường hay chia sẻ về Doraemon
rất nhiều và bàn luận về với nhau về nội
dung câu chuyện rất là
nhiều tuy nhiều người bảo là đấy chuyện
này trẻ con nhưng mà tính ra ấy là
chuyện đấy dành cho mọi lứa tuổi và đặc
biệt là tác giả của của Doraemon đấy có
viết rất nhiều on shot rất nhiều chuyện
khác nó có mang chiều sâu và mang kiểu
tầm nhìn đi trước Khởi đại rất rất nhiều
rất rất nhiều luôn Ví dụ điển hình mấy
ông thấy bảo bối Doraemon các thứ thứ
Thế mấy ông thấy là tương lai dần bây
giờ đang dần đang có những cái điều đấy
mà trong khi đó tác giả viết cái đấy từ
rất là lâu rồi thì mới biết là tầm nhìn
như th nào Hoặc là những cái câu chuyện
mà chuyện dài nó càng phân tích cụ thể
hơn về cái khái niệm về khoa học hay các
thứ thứ Ờ mới biết được là à tác giả
cũng có não có nhiều sạn Như đúng không
ạ tương tự thế với kiểu
à Tôi định nói thêm
tại thứ nhất thì tôi vẫn tự nhận tôi là
một qu bu cho dù không phải
là không cuồng lắm nhưng mà tôi vẫn tự
nhận tôi một wibu wibu là kiểu dạng là
cũng tương đối cuồng so với từ Otaku à
đúng không đây thôi tôi sử tra
nhá
VIB V với
otako là gì
cách kiểu Dạ cuồng nhiệt kiểu kiểu thế
yêu thích quá mức này xa đạa đấy Otaku
là sở thích mạnh mẽ với anime manga văn
hóa Nhật Bản đấy các thứ nó mang tí
nghĩa tích cực hơn nhưng tôi vẫn tự nhận
tôi làb bởi vì tôi ảnh hưởng nó khá sâu
sắc hơn vì tính ra ấy Thực ra tôi nghĩ
là tôi thường hay chêu mọi người là ai
cũng là một viib cả bởi vì bởi vì sao
tôi lại quay lại về cái văn hóa Nhật Bản
nó là mấy ông ở đây đọc truyện tranh
Nhật Bản nhiều hơn hay truyện tranh nước
nhà nhiều hơn mấy ông hiểu toàn bộ
truyền thống nước nhà bằng truyền thống
văn hóa Nhật Bản nhiều hơn không Ví dụ
điển hình Doraemon chẳng hạn các bạn sẽ
thấy là các bạn biết được một vài cái
ngày truyền thống của Nhật Bản thông qua
câu chuyện đấy thậm chí là phong cách ăn
mặc thông qua chuyện đấy Kiểu Kim monono
rồi Cá thứ thứ là những dịp gì hoặc là
tôi tôi nhớ là tôi còn nh biết được ngày
Cá Tháng Tư kiểu ngày quốc tế tôi nhớ
Chính xác cái đấy luôn phải có một tập
về cái đấy qua truyện damon hết kểu thế
nghĩa là nó chỉ
là là tính ra thì tôi tôi hồi bé tôi đã
đọc rất nhiều chuyện tranh nước nhà nhá
Ví dụ như thế Quậy này à thần ồng nướ
Việt này Ồ còn cái gì
nhỉ
Ừ thẽ tranh gì nữ
mà ám chỉ mình Trạng Quỳnh á Thực ra
Trạng Quỳnh cũng là một kiểu phiên bản
từ thần đông Đất Việt thì nó cũng ra từ
Trạng Quỳnh thôi nghĩ chỉ thực ra truyện
tranh nước nhà cũng khá là ít để mà mình
đập không lắm là mình đọc truyện tranh
cổ tích thôi Ừ nhưng tôi biết được một
vài truyện tranh cổ tích đấy nhưng mà nó
không nói nó có khác họa lên một tí văn
hóa con người Việt các thứ thứ nhưng mà
đấy là thời của tôi không biết là thời
các bạn kiểu bây giờ các bạn chắc là
cũng nhiều bạn trẻ hơn
tôi sợ thành gvt 3.5 à Ờ bốn chấm Tôi
vừa sử dụng hết rồi có vẻ nó đang giấy
hạn Tôi vừa dùng bốn chấm nó bảo là
Limit đến 8:00 tối ngày hôm nay 84n mấy
phút Chứng tỏ là mình cũng lạm dụng dùng
nó quá nhiều
thấy là nó cũng ảnh hưởng đến cái tô
tưởng suy nghĩ của chính mình chứ đừng
nói đến thế hệ sau là mình đang dần dần
cũng bị đùng hóa không biết đùng hóa mọi
thứ gì không Nhưng mà mình ví dụ cái
điển hình nhất gần đây đó là tôi cảm
thấy tôi cảm thấy thế nhá tôi hôm trước
tôi cũng nói chuyện
với tiền bối của tôi xếp cấp trên thì
tôi cảm thấy là kiểu
à mình đang nói chung là mình đang
kiểu hội nhập hóa kiểu dạng là tiếp thu
nền văn hóa nước ngoài và bắt đầu kiểu
quên mất đi cái những cái cái phong tục
truyền thống hay nền văn hóa của mình Ví
dụ ví dụ cái mấy ông biết được
à Sắp tới đến ngày lễ gì không ngày lễ
gì của nước ngoài mà không phải của mình
nhưng mà ai ai cũng Hảo hức đấy C thử
thử 21 Bạn đang xem Tôi nghĩ là chỉ có
một vài người trả lời thôi như tôi nghĩ
ai cũng đều biết được sắp tới là ngày gì
ạ Ừ sắp tới là ngày 25 tháng 12 ngày
giáng sinh cái gì gì đó đúng đấy bạn trở
lời được đấy không phải là ngày của mình
đúng không ạ Mấy ông không theo đạo đúng
không ạ Mấy ông nói thẳng là rất nhiều
ông ở đây còn không không biết được
là không biết được là kiểu nguồn gốc của
ngày đấy
à Ừ đúng Nó không phải là của nước ngoài
bởi vì nhiều người theo đạo có ở Việt
Nam thì nó vẫn là ngày
của của mình của Nói chung là đấy theo
Đức tin tôi thì tôi không Tôi không kiểu
kiểu
có thường một cái đức tin của một ai cả
nhưng mà tôi đang nói là chuẩn là ngày
đấy là của ngày tôi tôi theo tôi hiểu
theo tôi hiểu thôi đó là ngày đấy là
ngày chuẩn của những người theo Đức tin
về đạo mà đúng
không với tôi và cái cái đấy nhá tại sao
tôi lại dùng từ của nước ngoài bởi vì rõ
ràng nó vẫn là xuất thân từ nước ngoài
về chứ truyền thống mình không có cái
đấy chứ tôi không nói cụ thể là nó là
của xuất thân nó của nước nào vì tôi
không biết tôi không tìm hiểu cái đấy
thật nhưng mà ý tôi là ý tôi ở đây tôi
không Tôi vẫn khẳng định là tôi không
phê phán hay là kiểu bảo là mình không
nên đón ngày đấy mà đang nói là ngày đấy
Ngày đấy thì đ đó nhận các thứ thứ đúng
không ạ nhưng mà so với những ngày
truyền thống của mình thì không hề được
đón nhận như thế đặc biệt là với giới
trẻ hiện tại đúng không ạ Nói thẳng Tôi
cũng không biết được toàn bộ tất cả các
ngày truyền thống của của nương
mình tôi cảm thấy là nó cứ bị kiểu không
biết là có phải do bản thân tôi không
hay
là do mình đang bị kiểu
Ừ đấy kiểu dạng là cái văn hóa mình cũng
có thể đang bị F Mở đi có nghĩa là thế
Ờ ví dụ giống như là hồi trước tôi tôi
tôi có nghe tôi có đọc ở đâu đấy không
nhớ rõ nguồn lắm đó
là tôi cũng không biết đúng hay không
chưa xác thực được tất cả kiến thức mình
đọc bây giờ chủ yếu ở trên mạng mà Đó là
kiểu đối với nhậ bản thì hình như là trẻ
em tiểu học lớp 1 lớp hai hay đểm chỉ
lớp 3 gì đấy thì sẽ không Học mấy cái
môn đại cương mình đang học kiểu hồi
tiểu học theo kiểu toán văn hay hay là
mấy môn gì gì đó mà họ sẽ họ còn à Mấy
em đấy không Thi mà em đấy chủ yếu là
học Văn hóa để mà hiểu hơn về văn hóa và
truyền thống của chính nước
mình tôi thấy nó cũng một cái hay để mà
kiểu
mình mình nhớ nguồn Cuội các thứ các thứ
mình có lòng tự tôn ấy mấy ông hiểu
không Tôi vẫn đang nói về khái niệm tự
tôn kiểu mình cái cho mình yêu nước xong
mình kiểu nhớ V muốn cội các thứ các thứ
đúng không
À đương nhiên đấy vẫn là kiểu gấp nhìn
của tôi thôi tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi kiểu
đọc xong rồi hơi nghĩ bay bổng một tí nó
không Không hẳn là thực tế cho lắm theo
kiểu
à Kiểu nào nhỉ thỉnh thoảng tâm sự nó có
tí vĩ mô tí đúng
Ok
tôi tôi Thỉnh thả tôi muốn tâm sự một
cái đấy thì tính ra đây vẫn là một cái
kênh kiểu Tôi muốn tâm sự chia sẻ một
góp Nhìn gì
đó của một đấy Kiểu một vơ một wibu một
một một người là làm lập chính viên
nhưng thực ra là có cái nhìn nó cũng hơi
dị dị một
react thì chắc không rõ rồi
Ờ cái này chắc phải hỏi ở trên những
những cái nhóm
nhưng mà những nhóm kiểu sinh viên các
thứ các thứ hoặc là trên mạng chắc là
cũng có đấy thậm chí hỏi CHT này có khi
ra đấy Tôi đang gặp các tas về hiệu năng
ứng dụng khi có quá nhiều lần
dispar
của mỗi lần kéo thả cho ông dụng kéo thả
tôi không hiểu câu hỏi này
tháng 10 bắt nguồn từ thiên chúa giáo
Đúng rồi hình như là nó bắt nguồn vẫn là
từ một cái đạo nào đó đúng không Nhưng
mà kiểu dạng là cái cái ngày đấy được
đón nhận kiểu thực ra là mình nói thẳng
luôn là kiểu mình cũng theo phong trào
chủ yếu mình theo phong trào kiểu Thấy
nó hay thì mình cũng không tìm hiểu kỹ
Nhưng mà mình kiểu cũng kiểu mình có cớ
để đi để mà đi chơi để đi quẩy thôi
chẳng hạn để
diện nhưng mà ám chỉ là cái ngày nó kiểu
vì vì nó có một cái gì gì đó như thế
đúng không Mình có lý do để mà
kiểu nhớ đế nó hơn diện hơn các thứ thứ
thế nó giống như kiểu dịp Tết ấy có cớ
mà diện ấy đấy thì rõ ràng là đấy là một
cái kiểu cái
hay tôi vẫn bảo tôi bảo là nó không tôi
không phản đối ngày đấy nhưng mà tôi cảm
thấy là ngày đấy đang được đón nhận hơn
đúng không so với những ngày truyền
thống của mình thế nên là mình phải
mình cũng nên nghĩ phải có cách gì đấy
để khiến cho những ngày kia nó phải được
tương tự đúng không ạ Ít nhất là tương
tự đã chưa nói
thanh toán vào hệ
không ạ
Ờ không biết ông câu hỏi Chính xác là gì
lắm Ờ nhưng mà nếu mà ông đang nói là
tôi sẽ hướng dẫn làm cổng thanh toán
à Thì tôi tôi định là về sau sẽ có ở
trong cái dự oán dự án web bán hàng này
Ừ chắc là tôi sẽ thử tích hợp cổm thanh
toán
Ờ đương nhiên là tôi từng làm tích hợp
cổm thanh toán sty hay là Paypal rồi và
tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ làm thêm vài cổng nữa vì
cảm thấy ở ví dụ thanh toán ở Việt Nam
Thực ra nó sẽ không thông qua những cái
cổng kia mình có thể dùng cho nhều cách
khác Ừ có thể tích hợp Momo đấy cũng
được Cũng một cách Thực ra là tích hợp
mấy thằng về cơ bản thì nó cũng chỉ khác
nhau một tí thôi mình cũng hiểu được cái
luồng hoạt động nó ở
được Nghĩ lập trình game ổn không không
biết trả lời nha Chắc chắn là kiểu các
bạn thích cái gì Các bạn cứ làm một TH
các bạn sẽ hiểu
phỏng vấn gì Chắc các bạn chịu khó tìm
kiếm thì hơn chứ hỏi tôi cũng
không không trả lời được mấy cái
mới như Framework thì học như nào ạ
Ờ Thực ra tôi tôi B từng bảo mấy ông rồi
là tôi làm tôi khi mà tôi động vào bên
larel này hoặc là j hoặc là gần đây nhất
là view n view có Framework là njs ấy
thì chủ yếu là tôi đọp code người trước
chứ thực ra tôi không nên hẳn trang chủ
để đọc đặc biệt với thằng larel luôn
larel trang chủ nó khá là khó đọc và
hiểu so với một
fơ bởi vì tính ra thậm chí là càng lên
phiên bản càng cao nó càng rút ngắn tài
liệu lại kiểu gần như thế nó sẽ chỉ nói
thêm cái mới ở cái cái phiên bản này
hoặc là nó tích hợp sang cái đầu đâu đấy
ví dụ nó có những cái đoạn code nó có
những đoạn code mình không hề biết được
nó nên nằm ở trong cái chỗ nào kiểu thế
nên tính ra là cái trang này nó không
phải là dễ cho người mới nên
là mình đôi khi ở học lập trình mình
phải mò làm dần xong mình mới
là làm tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa COD
trước rồi dần dần mình sẽ vỡ lẽ ra
ngu mới học thì không ai khẳng định được
ai Lúc đầu cũng đầy cái cần phải học các
thứ các thứ mới học mà giỏi thì có khi
em đang học sai rồi ai học mới học cái
tôi hôm hôm nay tôi vừa bình luận một
cái bài năng Người ta bảo là
ờ đến cuối năm nhất rồi mà học không
hiểu gì là kém tôi bình luận trong bài
đấy bảo là tôi đến năm cuối tôi mới bắt
đầu hiểu được nhưng mà tôi vẫn đi làm
được Tôi không tự nhận tôi kém gì cả chỉ
nói là kiểu Ừ thì mình học chậm hiểu
chậm hơn người khác vân vân mình không
quan trọng mình vẫn mình vẫn cố gắng
gắng mình cảm thấy là mình cả ngày mình
càng tiến bộ lên và mình tin là mình làm
được ờ rồi vẫn làm ra được một cái gì đó
chọn Ctrl Đó là một disp để lưu Ctrl để
lưu vào Ctrl chọn sau đó thôi cũng
vẫn Ờ bạn kia bình luận như
kiểu ừ
vậy không hiểu
ngày B code lên git code được đẩy lên
tất cả trừ hôm nay biết vì sao
không có thể em ngồi kiểm tra lại cái
git ex hoặc là Ừ về git được các An chưa
gặp một cái lỗi này lắm Anh dùng cái A
git desktop nên thành ra là kiểu nó sẽ
nó kiểu có những cái file trên ở đây nó
hiển thị ra hết thôi em kiểm tra git
ignor các thứ các thứ là được
Ờ Còn không thì chắc là em có thể Ừ tôi
lại bảo team view với ông nào đó ở trên
discord nên sợ ông nào đó vào hack nick
à hack máy bạn ấy
hai s đúng không Đúng rồi khóa này có
dạy mongo để làm hai cơ sở dữ liệu không
anh
ờ thực tế là tôi gần có định làm mongo
nhưng không phải với cái dự án này mà
tôi định làm mongo dự án sau nữa nên là
xong khi mà xong dự án này thì tôi sẽ
tìm hiểu mongo tôi tìm hiểu thôi tôi
chưa chắc là dạy được mấy ông nhưng tôi
sẽ ngồi lúc đấy tôi sẽ like code để tìm
hiểu của mấy
là dài kiểu nó bị cắt ấy ờ Tôi nghĩ là
ông nên hỏi trên kênh discord thì hợp lý
không
à à nh hợp lý hơn để mà kiểu dễ theo dõi
à dễ trả lời hơn ấy anh có còn dạy ở FPT
không chính xác là
tôi sang năm sẽ dạy ở bft Tôi định là
như
thế Ờ tâm sự chắc là cũng tương đối rồi
Cái này chắc để buổi sau mấy ông nghe
thử cái này nhá thì để buổi sau tôi thử
tâm sự với mấy ông về cái này và mấy ông
có thể lên kênh lên cái link mà tôi đính
kèm ấy để mấy ông theo dõi xem mà tôi
tôi thường hay nốt ở trong này nó hình
như nó có ghi là kiểu cập nhật lần cuối
là bao giờ thì
là bao giờ kiểu nó hiển thị ra cập nhật
lần cuối là bao giờ để biết được là à nó
mới được cập nhật ấy để mấy ông vào xem
cũng được chứ bây giờ như này không biết
đường Ngọc một lần
kiểu cập nhật các thứ vào trong này tôi
tôi kiểu định chia sẻ mấy ông cái gì đó
định tầm sự gì đó thì mấy ông để xem
trước kiểu à xem trước Ừ buổi hôm nay C
chống vẻ hay như cái kiểu mình muốn xem
chẳng hạn đấy Kiểu thế tôi lại hơi lười
làm quả mục lục để chia nên thành ra
kiểu mấy ông ngồi xem cả video kiểu
livestream này hai tiếng ngồi mò xem Tôi
định nói cái gì th ra hơi khó n tôi Hơi
bị lười thông cảm kiểu cũng không thời
gian để ngồi làm cái đấy nếu mà ai mà
kiểu chịu khấu ngồi xem đánh mục lục của
tôi thì tôi cảm
Ừ chưa Tôi định Ừ nếu bạn còn nhớ thì
đúng là tôi
định sang bên anh Huy ở bên wecommit để
mà đăng ký một khóa học kiểu nâng cao
hơn về SQL Ừ nhở tôi định đáng ẽ là phải
định học cái đấy Nói chung là học mọi
thứ chán chê đã rồi xang bfd dạy cho
ngon nhưng mà
Ờ bây giờ đúng là cũng chưa thời gian để
mà đi học hay làm mọi thứ thật chắc là
để tôi phải sắp xếp lại ông ông không
nhắc tôi quên
đấy bạn kia nhắc cái thứ năm Ừ thứ năm
tôi nhắc lại cho mấy ông là thứ năm tuần
này tôi nghĩa là hai hôm hai hôm nữa
nghĩa buổi sau ấy thì tôi xin phép nghỉ
để tôi
đi kiểu đám cưới của ông anh ông anh
người đã dẫn tôi vào đời
nên là
ờ nên là buổi sau mình tạm nghỉ một buổi
nhá thì chắc là buổi hôm nay có thể dài
hơn và buổi sau nữa thể dài hơn để bù
lại cũng được hôm nay chia sẻ mấy ông
rất nhiều này chia sẻ rất nhiều
em bỏ 8 tháng để đi thực
tập à Làm Bên mảng x x cậu cộng giờ em
quay lại thấy Xa Lạ của anh Thực ra thì
à ngôn ngữ với tôi nó không quan trọng
ông thấy xa lạ thì có khi là ừ th đương
nhiên ông nhìn thì có góc nhìn khác kiểu
càng làm nhiều thì ông sẽ càng thấy kiểu
Ừ
kiểu gọi càng học càng biết mình kiểu
còn nhiều điều cần phải học ấy không sao
về equ á thì ông vào playlist của tôi ôn
lại cũng được kì học phí bên đó thế nào
anh hỏi thăm chưa Tôi từng hỏi rồi nhưng
mà vì hỏi nhắn tin riêng nên là anh ấy
đưa một cái giá cũng kiểu hình như là
cũng theo cá nhân riêng thì phải kiểu
Anh ấy xem qua hồ sơ của tôi rồi anh ấy
đánh giá đ là nó có thể hơi khác so với
mọi người nhưng mà tính ra tôi cũng
khuyên mấy ông Cái này nói đang định bảo
nói nhỏ thôi Nhưng mà thực ra đang công
khai nhưng mà chắc là chỉ có ba mấy
người ở đây nghe cùng đó về sau thêm vài
người nghe nữa Chắc không nhiều lắm
nghĩa
là tôi tôi vẫn khẳng định l Tôi không
phải con người có điều kiện nên thành ra
là thế là thành ra là tôi thường Muốn
tận dụng triệt để cái kiểu dạng là kiểu
những cái những cái mà mình không mua
được không phải không mua được bằng tiền
dùng tử không đúng lắm bạn
nha những thứ mà mình phải phải trả tiền
cho nó ấy Kiểu kiểu thế trả cái gì đó ấy
Thôi thường haay đánh đổi nó bằng một
cái gì đó khác kiểu thay vì mình trả
bằng tiền mình có thể đánh đổi lại bằng
một cái gì đó khác kiểu tôi bên cùng có
lợi đấy Tôi đang ví dụ thế nghĩa là
à Tôi cảm thấy là tôi tận dụng rất tốt
về cái khoản đấy và kiểu tạo ra được rất
nhiều mối quan hệ các thứ các thứ thế
thành ra là khi mà tôi hỏi hay xin dùng
từ sinin cộng kiểu dạng là xin giảm giá
hay là xin chế khấu vân vân hoặc là thậm
chí là đi mấy cái sự kiện tôi xin quà cơ
cấu không hẳn là cơ cấu giải thưởng
nhưng cơ cấu để được
quà cơ cấu được quà đây không phải tranh
chấp quà với bất kỳ ai đâu nhá chị đang
nói là kiểu thay vì mình phải ngồi chơi
chơi được nhận quà thì bây giờ mình Mình
bảo là mình sẽ cơ cấu kiểu khác hay kiểu
thế nếu mà ông nào gặp tôi ngoài đời Đặc
Biệt sinh viên của tôi thì sẽ biết được
tôi cơ cấu đỉnh như thế nào Ví dụ tôi cơ
cấu được đi được vé đi một cái sự kiện
chẳng ạ
đấy thì công nhận là tôi thấy nhiều lúc
tôi mặt dày thật Nhưng mà thực sự thì ờ
bởi vì mình biết được là ví dụ điển hình
nhá Thôi Gần đây tôi đi mấy cái sự kiện
ở bên web submit à web submit của bên
tốt dep à Hay lẫn cả lẫn cả Mobile
submit gì gì đấy
thì bản chất là mấy cái hội thảo về công
nghệ như thế thì có cácc gian hàng các
thứ đúng không ạ thì các gian hàng đấy
người ta khi một khi người ta mang quà
đến ý thì code thứ nhất là người ta luôn
muốn người ta phát hết chứ không phải là
người ta mang quà đến rồi người ta muốn
mang quà về trả niểm gì cả thì người ta
sẽ thường hay kiểu muốn phát quà nhưng
mà chỉ thì nên kiểu họ đã sẵn sàng bỏ
tiền ra để mua cái quà đấy rồi là để là
để phát mà đúng không nhên Cái quan
trọng là khi họ phát thế họ một phát cho
những cái gọi là những người mà họ cảm
thấy xứng đáng họ cảm thấy là kiểu Ừ
mình đổi lại được một cái gì đó Vân Vân
đấy chứ thực ra mấy ông ngồi chơi chơi
các thứ thứ họ code ở kiểu để cho gọi là
không phải phát miễn phí V mấy ông thôi
đấy kể thế thì mấy ông cảm thấy là mấy
ông có những cái ưu điểm gì Ví dụ là
kiểu nhì nhiều Ông đăng ký được đăng ký
kiểu đăng ký tuyển dụng thẳng vào công
ty họ thì họ sẽ phát quá đấy một cách
tôi đang ví dụ thôi Nhưng mà thường là
tôi sẽ
kiểu tận dụng thêm những cái khác
nữa thì đấy một cách cơ cấu của
tôi Ơ tự nhiên nói lan man quá ờ qu lại
một tí đầu tiên thì tôi muốn nói ông Cái
này
à Bây giờ tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng có
thể Kể cả bây giờ đang là fer Junior hay
thậm chí là xor thử thử kiểu bỏ một buổi
ra để ngồi làm cái trang web kiểu về
thiệp cưới Thực ra còn bây giờ là thờ
đại bây giờ là công nghệ nào cũng có và
đặc biệt là có nhiều bên cho thuê cái
kiểu làm cái template các thứ thứ trong
web th K Ới rồi nhưng là tôi đang nói là
mấy ông thử
ngồi tự tự làm hẳn một cái trang web th
thiệp cưới cho bản thân mình xem nào đấy
mấy ông thể đính kèm thêm kiểu
Ờ ảnh của bản thân mình với ảnh của CR
hay là người yêu hiện tại vân vân hoặc
là ảnh anime nào đó cũng được đấy thì
code là khi làm cái này tôi nghĩ là đấy
là cái điểm hay của anh em Làm lập trình
đó là anh em có thể nhìn được luôn thành
thành quả bản thân mình người khác thì
khó nhìn được điều đấy Còn mình làm giao
diện kiểu nhìn trông nó đẹp như xấu như
nà mình thấy được luôn đấy
à Thì mấy ông làm trang web đấy Tôi nghĩ
là trong lúc làm trang web đấy Tuy là
tôi là một người làm gia diện xấu nhá
như là tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng sẽ
tự thậm chí là mấy ông có thể viết mấy
cái mô tả ngắn là kiểu mình gặp nhau như
thế nào rồi người kia như th nào vân vân
vân kể cả cho dù Cho dù là ông chưa đang
chưa có ng yêu hay kiểu thấy ông có thể
viết ra một cái viễn cảnh gì gì đó làm
trước đi Tôi nghĩa là làm trước đi Nó
gần như là để cho mấy ông Tự vẽ ra cái
bức tranh tương lai của ông sẽ thế nào
ấy đấy để cho mấy ông
tự tự cảm thấy hạnh phúc hạnh phúc trong
thoáng chốc v cái điều đấy mấy ông sẽ có
thêm động lực hơn rất nhiều để mà theo
cái ngành này tôi nghĩ là như thế trừ
khi mà Mấy ông làm trong web tr xấu xấu
kinh khủng rồi m Ông cảm thấy là không
phù
hợp chịu lúc ấy để lúc ôm template ở CH
ở ở bên n đó
về nhưng mà ý tôi là như thế nghĩa là
đôi khi là tôi cảm thấy là làm website
thiệp cưới này cũng là một cái pet
Project mình khi làm mình sẽ rất là vui
kiểu thế thậm chí là mình làm xong kiểu
gì mình ch chẳng muốn đi khoe đi khoe CR
chẳng hạn đi khoe chì gì đó không có
người nào để khoe thích ông gửi tôi Khoe
với tôi cũng được chúng mình Cù Cùng
cười đấy nghĩa là tôi thấy đáng nẽ cái
này hồi trước hồi mà tôi dạy về web làm
kiểu làm giao Diệu g cơ bản đáng nẽ là
tôi phải phải cho mấy ông làm cái
project này để mấy ông thấy vui mà đúng
không tự làm tự
xem m ông Tự vẽ ra bước tranh cho chính
mình
cho tuần sau
nộp đ bây giờ tuần sau mới bắt đầu
livestream lại mà hình như là lộ rất là
lâu rồi rồi không ra bài tập gì chong
mấy ông thức ra tôi bởi vì bây giờ chuẩn
chuẩn là cái khóa đầu tôi dạy là bây giờ
đi nên đi làm mà đi thực tập rồi nên
cũng không thời gian để ngồi làng bài
tập nữa nhưng mà đang nói là kiểu à đấy
như tôi bảo Thì cái này nó không phải
quan tâm Không quan tâm về việc là
đang là Junior senio hay là fer đúng
không bản chất là làm cái này mấy ông tự
thấy vui đương nhiên ông làm ông xio thì
làm kiểu trông nó đẹp hơn đúng không Ông
fesser thì làm kiểu khác đấy các thứ thứ
tôi kém CS mà chúng ta ôm giao diện về
Quan trọng là mấy ông dựng được cái
khung r dạy dựng đủ thứ Và thậm chí là
ông nào làm nâng cao hơn thì code hẳn pp
đấy so m để tích hợp thêm tính năng gì
đó tùy Thực ra đây trong gép Tĩnh cũng
được đấy Nói chung là mấy ông làm kiểu
gì thiên biến vạn hóa kiểu gì đấy Cái
quan trọng là lúc mà Ông làm đấy Tôi tin
là ông làm cái này sẽ vui hơn và cảm
thấy kiểu hình dung ra được cái tự vẽ
nên bức tranh của chính mình mà tương
lai của chính mình mình sẽ thấy háo hức
hơn so với làm bất kỳ cái cái khác ông
đang làm tôi nghĩ là như thế trừ khi ông
không muốn cưới lúc ấy chịu thì ông
chuyển qua làm cưới mấy em Anime này
lolly chẳng
hạn
à đấy Thử nhá Tôi tạm một cái th ở trên
trên này
nhá Đây thườ thường các bạn gọi THT gì à
web site thiệp cưới mấy ông tra Google
gi đầy đúng không đấy
trả bài vào ở đây
nhé yêu cầu link không cần s
code đó mấy ông thích vẽ vẽ vờ gì trong
này m ông kiểu đăng vào trong đấy những
tôi định làm bây gi tôi thử nói ý tưởng
tôi hồi trước làm thiệp cưới nhá đó hồi
trước tôi cũng định làm kiểu thế nghĩa
là Thực ra bây giờ nó phổ biến rồi chứ
hồi hồi đấy là mình đã định làm kiểu để
cho nó đặc biệt Bởi mình dân công nghệ
mà đấy nghĩa là gửi link cho họ để mà họ
kiểu vào thì tích xem là họ có đi hay
không í nhất là như thế thì mình xác
định được ngĩ là việc là à thêm kiểu ví
dụ giới thiệu Menu đồ ăn để họ tích vào
xem là họ sẽ như ăn những món gì vì tính
ra Tính ra nhá Tôi tôi là một người kiểu
hơi kè ăn nên thành ra tôi sẽ khá khó
chịu khi mà không được chọn hoặc là ít
nhất là phải biết trước cái menu nó sẽ
như nào để mình ăn trước chẳng hạn mấy
lần đến quả ví dụ tôi không ăn được hài
sàn tự nhiên đến quả kiểu đồ ăn hầu như
toàn hài sàn làm kiểu ăn rất là đói khó
chịu ấy đấy ít nhất là kiểu hiển thị ra
hết trước xong rồi Gần đây tôi biết được
đám cưới gần đây là đám cưới Việt hảo
thì lên đấy xem ảnh cưới này xem câu
chuyện của họ này Đấy xong rồi xem nói
chung xem rất nhiều thứ thậm chí trên
đấy còn có cả mã qu để mà gửi chuyển
khoản mừng cưới Mỗi tội cả hai mã đều
đều là tài khoản cô
dâu không biết có sắp đặt gì không chắc
là không đâu
gọn hả Tôi có lên ý tưởng này đâu Ông
nhầm sang ai rồi bây giờ chuyển anh kiếm
được mồi x à không Ờ tôi thì ra tôi vẫn
đang suy nghĩ rất nhiều
đình các thứ thứ nó vẫn chuyện trọng đại
nhưng mà cái vụ thiệp cười này tôi nghĩ
lâu
rồi có khi có khi là tôi sẽ làm cái này
trước khi làm kiếm được ai đó Chắc chắn
bao gồm cả th cười Ừ chắc là dùng từ đấy
cũng đúng nghĩa là kiểu nó website kiểu
kiểu mô tả với mọi thứ và bao gồm cả mờ
luôn Nếu mà bao gồm cả mời luôn thì tốt
Tôi định là kiểu Tôi định làm cái này
mấy ông thể bắt trước tôi chia sẻ để mấy
ông thể tham Khảm
mà tôi định làm cũng cũng kiểu kỳ công
hơn đấy nghĩa là
Ờ gì nhỉ Tôi sẽ chuẩn là tôi làm cái
link đấy nhưng mà mấy cái link này một
cái link link tổng quát là kiểu vào thì
sẽ kiểu hiển thị toàn bộ thông tin Tổng
quát bao gồm cả form để mà mình tự điền
tên với cái cái của Việt thạo thì nó là
tên email xong rồi các thứ
để không phải tên email tên này xong rồi
lời trúc này ít nhất như thế Ừ hoặc là
link Facebook gì gì đó tôi tôi thì định
làm kiểu dạng là link nó sẽ kèm theo một
con số gì đó một cái username của họ ví
dụ abc đây link mình nhá rồi xộc như thế
này nó sẽ là kiểu username của họ ví dụ
NL như này chẳng hạn khi tôi gửi tôi sẽ
đầu tiên tôi sẽ tạo cái link này user
này username này chính là username
Facebook và tốt nhất chẳng hạn thế xong
rồi gửi cái link này cho họ khi khi mà
họ bấm vào thì nó đã Điền sẵn họ tên của
người người đấy rồi đúng không ạ hoặ
thậm chí chẳng cần phải điền sẵn họ tên
gần như là ẩn đi họ đỡ phải điền được
chỉ biết được à link đấy là là để chào
mừng mỗi bạn này thôi Kiểu thế chào Long
chẳng hạn đấy Xong rồi Long hãy đến đám
cưới của tôi vân vân vân X có nút ở dưới
có xác nhận có đi hay không đấy kểu thế
để mà về sau mình lưu và DB biết được là
Ừ cái ông kiểu ông Long này có cái link
Facebook vào như này ông ấy xác định là
đi đấy Kiểu như thế ít nhất như thế để
tôi nắm được là những cái người mà tôi
mời một cách kiểu riêng như thế khi họ
bấm vào link cụ thể như thế đúng không
thì những người đấy chắc chắn đi Lúc ấy
tôi sẽ qu tôi sẽ kiểu sắp xếp biết cách
sắp xếp mâm với các thứ thứ mọi thứ nó
khác Tôi nghĩ là như thế Nói chung là
tôi cũng nghĩ khá là cầu ký rất nhiều
cho mình còn chưa có ai
cả nhưng mà tôi cũng nghĩ cầu kỳ như thế
trước rồi đương nhiên là về sau có thể
không như mong đợi vì không biết là ông
nào đấy cưới chứ ông có thể chia sẻ thêm
bởi vì tính ra tôi thấy là còn phải mời
họ hạ các thứ thứ lăng nhă nữa vân vân
ông nào còn đi với thằng yêu đù kiểu nữa
chắc chắn là mọi thứ nó khác so với kiểu
mình lên kế hoạch nhưng mà Thì thế nên
tôi mới bảo là vẫn có một link tổng quát
để họ có thể bấm vào và họ tự điền tên
với họ tự điền số lượng người đi các th
các thứ để để họ nói chung là để mình
nắm sơ qua còn cái link kia là link
riêng thì để những người đặc biệt thôi
Kiểu như
thế n nó lại hơi dài quá thôi nhưng mấy
ông hình dung được tôi nói gì mà đúng
không tiếp nhá github read me Hồi trước
tôi
từng chia sẻ mấy ông về cái trang G của
rồi nhưng mà gần đây có một bên đăng lại
nên là tôi lại thích khoe lại phát nữa đ
Tôi nghĩ tôi thấy là nhiều ông cũng có
vẻ không để ý mặt mà cái đấy
lắm giờ tôi lên git Hub của tôi chẳng
đó nhạy cảm đúng không Chắc không đâu Ờ
lên trang git Hub của tôi th ra tôi về
sau tôi chắc tôi ẩn hết đúng ấy cái ảnh
ở trên giao diện Đắc là trông hơi Đắc
chả nhìn cái gì cả Chắc là để sửa lại
xong
diện màu trắng sáng thì chắc là sáng sủa
hơn
ờ thì đây là cái hồi trước tôi cũng tham
khảo rất nhiều bên mấy ông bây giờ tra
nó còn chắc chắn còn nhiều hơn đó là
cách để mà tạo ra một cái trang kiểu đối
với dân công nghệ anh em mình thì cái
trang kit Hub cũng là một trong những
cái trang kiểu như một cái CV của mình
một cái kiểu mang bản sắc riêng của mình
đúng không ạ Nên là Trang này tôi nghĩ
là cũng nên đầu tư một
tí kiểu trông nó ngầu ngầu mà đúng không
cái này tự cập nhật thật đấy nhá Đây mày
không thấy à cái đoạn này chắc chưa sửa
lại
Ờ cái này kiểu của tôi là cập nhật này
cập nhật lần cuối này thấy không Tôi tôi
làm cái vụ để nó tự độ cập nhật các TH
thứ lấy cập nhật cả spotify đang nghe gì
này Đấy cái thống kê này cũng có vẻ nó
đúng đấy mấy cái thống kê đúng hết đấy
Cái này qu time
này cái này thì ra không đúng lắm Bởi vì
tôi chúng ta không code ở trên gith tôi
code ở trên kênh khác nên thành ra cái
này mấy cái này không hẳn là đúng lắm
Thôi kệ chắc là tôi Xóa sau cái này cũng
cũng chắc là cũng tương tự
nhưng mà còn cái này là bởi vì tôi làm
YouTube và tôi có trang Block riêng nên
có cái này nhưng mà tôi tôi thử nói qua
để mấy ông hình dung được là cái trang
này của mấy ông cũng trông nó cũng ngầu
ngầu trong kiểu tự động th thứ này cũng
ngầu mà cái này thực tế đ nhá tắt tắ
Mode đi
h ảnh này mất đồ rồi Tại sao thành như
anh này có chữ mà chả hiểu nghe lỗi rồi
ch để tôi sửa t cái đ này xo
Uầy Không quen kiểu live kiểu này
hơn
đấy thì mấy ông hoàn toàn có thể kiểu
lên YouTube hoặc là lên nhiều nhiều
Trang nó dạy viết kup redm ha Mình làm
kiểu
thế tiếp theo nói nốt cái này cái này h
hôm nay xếp tôi mới chia sẻ thôi mới
biết được đó là hình như hình như là cái
này mấy ông phải mua chat gbt Plus thì
phải để mấy ông tạo một cái con như này
con này gần như là theo như tôi đang tìm
hiểu thì gần như là bình thường bình
thường là hôm trước mấy ông thấy tôi
dùng con captivity để mà trên cho
Training cho nó để nó viết test đúng
không ạ nhưng mà hình như có có vẻ nó
hơi bị kém V khoản đấy Kiểu nó nó vẫn
phải học lại
thứ các thứ và nó phải không chuyên về
cái đấy lắm thì tôi thấy là cái này có
vẻ là có vẻ là nó phù hợp hơn Hình như
thế đó là tôi tạo riêng Cái con này ví
dụ tôi gần đây tôi tạo riêng con này
trên công ty này generate test này để
tôi
đây có nghĩa là cái con này tạo con này
để chuyên cho một cái gì đó giống như
này đó thì tôi nghĩ nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
chắc thế biết đâu Mình Training một con
chuyên viết test kểu
hơn đúng
không
dùng ra tính đến bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa
chia sẻ mấy ông toàn bộ tất cả tiện í
đang dùng đúng không ạ
Ờ tich đang dùng
của của p Storm thì
đây những cái đang mở lên ví dụ là cái
này để chỉ sửa file nv này giao diện cái
pl trong đẹp hơn này chỉnh sửa được CSV
nhưng có vẻ gầ đây tôi không cần cái này
để mà chụp được cái kiểu screenshot này
copilot này cái này để biết được
là nó Nó là kiểu ch khá nhiều cái về git
ít nhất là biết được Kiểu chỉ dòng code
nào hiển thị ông nào viết đoạn này thì
play này đ Cái này cái gì T không nhớ
lắm
cách thì biết đấy Cái này để xem LCK
nhưng mà tôi không dùng này cái này cái
Gần đây tôi thấy là kiểu được tải nhiều
phết đ tôi thử tài thử để biết được là
nói chung là bình thường mình click
chuột các thứ thứ vì mình không nhiều
phím tắt ấ nó sẽ đề xuất ra kiểu máy nên
sử dụng phím đắt này hay vì kiểu bấm
chuột như thế để nó nhanh hơn cũng hay
query để gợi ý câu query này cái này
để để đề xuất một cái gì đó kiểu đề xuất
như này nhưng có vẻ là tôi
thấy không chạy tặt thư đi Để để nó tham
đúng
không cái này cái này một trong những
cái tôi khuyên mấy ông nên cà này bởi vì
cái này nó kiểu dạng là nó sẽ đề xuất
thêm những cái là kiểu đoạn code này
đáng lẽ là phải phải như nào hơn hoặc
thậm chí là nó còn đang bị sai cái gì đó
ông thì cái này m ông sẽ thấy nó kch báo
hơn đỏ lòm rất nhiều cái hoa K để đo xem
là mình kiểu ngồi codt Bao lâu này cái
này để mở được database trong này này
đer các thứ thứ này cái này đồng bộ gì
đó còn mấy cái dưới này thì tôi nghĩ là
mấy cái dưới này có vài cái Nó bật sẵn
cho mình rồi ấ Nhưng mà ông cứ phải đọc
kỹ để ông xem ông có dùng không ông tắt
đi tôi tắt rất nhiều cái ở dưới này luôn
đ tôi ngồi lướt qua mấy ông này tắt
nhiều cực cái nào Tôi không hiểu Tôi cứ
thử tắt thử đi Đây tắt à đâu p đ cer để
lại vậy ha hiểu nó cảnh báo nguy
hiểm không tôi cứ tắt
copilot rồi tắt sử cái này đi bùm
thường là mặc định cũng đủ để dùng rồi
bởi vì nó sẽ tinh chỉnh cho mấy ông khá
nhiều thứ rồi nhưng ý tôi đó ở đây đó
là tôi Tôi cảm thấy là mình là dân công
nghệ thì mình cảm thấy mình cũng phải m
mẫm nhiều hơn chứ không phải là kiểu nói
chung là mấy cái setting mấy cái tùy
chỉnh đấy chắc chắn là để dành cho gọi
là người ham vọc vạch đúng không Mình
cũng nên tò mò Mình cũng ham nên vọc
vạch tìm hiểu như cái chứ mình không nên
ở kiểu dạng như ngồi dùng phổ thông là
kiểu có gì sái nấy mình Không nên như
thế tôi khi mà mua một thiết đ bị đồ
công nghệ mới là tôi ngồi mỏ hết toàn bộ
cài đặt của nó à Tải phần mềm nà đó về
tôi cũng ngồi cả ngồi mò các thứ thứ thế
đ Tôi muốn kiểu dạng là bởi vì mấy cái
đấy mới là mấy cái tinh túy kiểu mình là
lập trình viên mà mình sẽ biết được là
làm m cái đoạn đấy mình tốn công đúng
không Thì phải có lý do để người ta làm
ra tính năng đấy đúng không không người
ta làm làm gì đúng không nế là thành ra
là kiểu Nếu mấy ông kiểu ham học hỏi Ham
như thế thì tôi nghĩ là cái đầu tiên cái
tư duy góc nhìn mình nó sẽ khác rất
nhiều nữa kiểu mình thấy à thằng này tự
nh nhiên có những cái cải đặt này nó hay
hơn hay hơn thằng kia vân
nhỉ tôi không để ý lắm là khi nào tôi
dạy đâu nhưng mà Ừ chắc là cũng có thể
thế kiểu cuối năm đúng
không thì tắt hết đ ngoài nà
luôn có được không Anh không nên em ơi
kiểu nên học từ từ đã không học larel
còn chẳng hiểu gì chứ Không nói bây giờ
còn đòi nhảy CP thì độ khó tăng hơn
nhiều
tiện hơn trong code vậy ạ
Ờ nếu mà em muốn một cái đơn giản mà em
chẳng cần vọc vạch gì nhiều thì đúng là
cái Editor là V code là đủ rồi còn anh
ham bóng vạch Anh ham tinh trỉnh rất
nhiều thứ nữa thì bản thân cái IDE nó hỗ
trợ tận răng nhiều gái hơn rất nhiều
giống như à Tôi quên chưa bảo mấy ông à
Tôi chưa nhờ xếp tôi cái cài đặt hỗ trợ
lại cái vụ K debug Hôm nay tôi ngồi kiểu
dùng cái IDE để chạy luôn chạy luôn test
các thứ ngon lành
à Chữ Project
Ờ nãy giờ ngồi tâm sự các thứ thứ ngầm
tiếng đồng hồ rồi chưa ngồi cố gì cả Bây
giờ giờ mình sẽ quay lại ngồi code nhá
đầu tiên là bây giờ hôm nay sẽ dạy mấy
ông hôm trước là tôi hướng dẫn mấy ông
về cách kiểu cách giữ liệu các thứ lại
rồi Bây giờ thì mình bài toán ở đây đó
là khi mình kiểu cách lưu nó lại thế
đúng không Thì bây giờ sẽ có lúc mình
phải xóa nó đi đúng không Thì những lúc
nào mình xóa nó đi
à Rõ ràng hôm trước đây mình thấy là mỗi
lần mình làm thì mình cách lại này mình
xóa phải xóa đi đúng không
đây thì thường thưởng là khi mà xóa tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ không dùng
obser không dùng obser cho lắm Tuy là
đây nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ thử code the
obser cho mày không hình dung đã nhá
này thôi tạo phìm tắt đấy
op không nhờ cái
lại server à
Ok
gì Cái này là cái này là kiểu khi mà
ông với điều kiện là khi mà ông khai báo
một thằng mod kiểu như này xong ông gọi
đến hàm crate của Nó kiểu như
này crate này một cái gì gì đó như này
thì thì nó sẽ kiểu
sẽ ở đây nó sẽ có những cái gì
là khi mà đã tạo xong này khi đã update
xong này khi khôi phục hoặc là khi Xóa
hẳn thứ là còn những cái event
nữa nhưng mà tôi bảo thường là tôi sẽ
không thường là tôi sẽ không dùng cái
cái này
Tại sao vì tôi muốn là như này đây tôi
tra tài liệu cho mấy ông
version 10 nó khác gì đâ
obser
à Không mod obser này updated deled cái
thứ này xong rồi trong bút thì khai báo
một cái obser
Ok hoặc là như kiểu
này lấy thông tin ra này nhưng mà đây
với điều kiện là cập nhật một đối tượng
thôi nhá Còn nếu mà ông kiểu VT thường
hàm crade thì nó cũng chỉ cập nhật một
đối tượng thôi nhưng update thì đúng là
có thể nhiều nhưng đây đang nói là chỉ
đang nói về cái hàng này nó sẽ xử lý cho
một đối tượng thôi nhá tức là nếu mà ông
update hay xử lý nhiều hình như tôi nhớ
là không được
đâu
quan tâm tất cả các event này lắm mà tôi
thường quan tâm cái event này này
updated này
modify và gọi đến kiểu đã lưu
ông khai báo th
kiểu trong này kiểu như này không biết
là cái này có chạy được không nhá một
ông khai báo kiểu nh như
này Uầy Quá hợp lý luôn nó gợi ý chuẩn
luôn là mình cần phải xóa kick key này
đó nhưng thực ra là nó ghi chuẩn hơn đầy
đủ nó như này
bao gồm việc update hoặc là create à à
đâu mình chỉ liên quan update thứ nhỉ
Chứ mình create xong thì mình cần gì
phải xóa cá key nhỉ đúng nhỉ mình thêm
mới mình xóa
Ừ cứ để cho update đi nếu mà mình nghĩ
đơn giản cứ để trong update đi đấy thì
mình sẽ xóa cách này còn nếu mà trong
trường hợp không có cách đấy không ra
không lỗi đâu
đấy thì đơn giản chỉ như này cứ mỗi lần
khi ông update thì ông xóa cách thì nó
sẽ không bị lỗi Bây giờ tôi cứ thử chạy
cho mấy ông dễ hình dung Lã nhá Ờ cái
panch này đúng không panch admin
homepage Này quay đi quay lại vẫn là mỗi
cái Trang config đấy đúng
không chạy hơi lâu th cảm yeah lỗi rồi À
đúng rồi Vừa nãy ở đây Ctrl Z
cách đúng
string cái gì tự
nhiên object class À hôm trước mà mình
hôm trước Mà mình xử
lý h trước là
À client đây Hôm trước mình sửa lại
thành như này mình sẽ đổi lại thành
value như này
đi bởi vì hôm trước mình cách lại cả đối
tượng mà Nhu mếu không
kiểu như này đúng không ạ Và mình đã kch
rồi đấy mình kch rồi đấy
Ờ cho xem pan cham des Scope
nhá này An không thấy là hit sử dụng
cách rồi đúng không ạ thế giờ Bây giờ
giả sử là tôi cập nhật Cái này tôi xóa
cái này đi chẳng hạn Chỉ cần xóa cái ảnh
dưới thôi submit này update này tải
trang này nó vẫn hiển thị cái cũ tại sao
bởi vì rõ ràng nó vẫn dùng cái kch cũ
đúng không ạ Thế nên là tôi bảo bây giờ
mình sẽ phải mở cái này lên nghĩa là mỗi
khi mà có cập nhật nhật thì mình xóa
cách cũ đi đúng không ạ Bây giờ tôi thử
thêm cái ở đây là như này hình như là nó
vẫn chưa chạy đâu phải khai báo đầy đủ
trong
thằng như mà ông thấy ở đây là phải khai
báo trong obser kể th này hoặc là bút
như này tôi thường kh báo trong bút hơn
thì nó là như này Alo bút này là bút
của even service
even service provider
này Đấy cái nhược điểm một khi ông khai
báo trong kiểu như này này nhiều người
không để ý đâu Kiểu t tự nhiên là kiểu
ông kiểu code ông hơi bị chích một tí
kiểu tự nhiên có một
cái tít ở đằng xa để để mà xử lý đúng
không theo tôi là nó sẽ gọi dùng từ chck
tức cả chỉ kiểu bản thân là kiểu
mình thấy là ừ nó đang kích lại như này
nhưng mình không thể biết được cái đoạn
xóa kch nó ở đâu trong cái trong cái m
đồ này mình đâu thấy chỗ nào đâu hóa ra
nó từ tít tận bên provider này xong gọi
đến hàng ngày phải xóa th thử
này đâu phết
nhỉ Chắc không lỗi
đấy xắc xịt này đó Bây giờ mới lên ok
chưa
thì thế nên là tôi theo cái cách mà tôi
thường hay làm đó là tôi thường hay khai
báo thẳng ở trong mod Nhưng mà đấy ở
trong trường hợp trong trường hợp mà là
ông ông cóít even và ông muốn kiểu gọi
như nào ông muốn code nó kiểu dễ hình
dung hơn thì ông vứt là mod đồ nhưng mà
đương nhiên thì nó sẽ bị cũng gọi là
không tốt lắm Bởi vì không tốt vì tôi
hôm trước tôi còn nói việc là tùy từng
nơi nó sẽ
chia các layer các xử lý ở các chỗ khác
nhau ấy Ví dụ điển hình điển hình nhá
cái đoạn kch này nhiều Nhiều người còn
bảo đoạn cách này không nên vứt ở trong
mồ bản chất là m đồ chỉ nên chỉ nên làm
liên quan đến xử lý đến cơ sở liệu thôi
việc lấy cơ sở việc lấy dữ liệu từ sử
liệu ra là của mồ còn việc kch thì nó
nằm ở chỗ khác nên là việc xóa kch nó
cũng phải nằm một chỗ khác luôn đấy kiểu
như thế Thế là tôi đang nói là tôi đang
hồi trước tôi bảo là tôi dạy theo kiểu
mvc theo kiểu là nó n nào giống mvc bây
giờ thôi tức là chị mua đồ nó sẽ ôm khá
nhiều cái xử lý ở trong này trừ những
cái đoạn logic rất là phức tạp thì tôi
sẽ vứt nó ra một cái Action một cái khác
sau còn bây giờ tôi vẫn muốn thằng Model
nó vẫn mình phải hiểu được à có chỗ
trong Model có cách thì trong Model cũng
nên có cái đoạn xóa cách để mình sẽ hình
dung hơn chứ không phải nằm trong event
service hay là trong kiểu như này thì
tức là sao tôi sẽ này tôi sẽ bắt trước ở
đây
cò tách hẳn những cái thng nhỏ nhỏ hơn
như này cũng là một cách này nên thường
tôi sẽ làm theo kiểu Đây nhìn
này
là bú tt như này xong rồi Khi
mà khi mà upd đúng
đấy Cái Ea thỉnh thoảng cảnh báo là kiểu
thêm cái satic nữa để nó có thể chạy
nhanh hơn có thể thế thôi Không biết
được đấy và cái đoạn này tất cả đoạn này
nói chung là cái file này tôi sẽ xóa đi
này Xóa đi even service Xóa đi
nhé xóa mấy cái dòng này đi này submit
này
hơi lâu kiểu chắc máy livestream n thành
ra hơi
đ ok rồi tạ Trang đấy vẫn được đúng
không Vẫn chạy thì mấy ông sẽ Hình dung
là là bây giờ mình khai đáo một cái
event nào đó mình sẽ có thể khai báo
theo cách kiểu như này cũng được đấy và
mình hoàn toàn có thể nắm rõ được Ừ đoạn
này là đoạn lấy cách ra đoạn này là đoạn
bạn kiểu ngồi xóa cách đúng không ạ
đấy xóa theoo cách key nhá đấy xóa cách
key này Đấy và lấy dạng theo cách key
này ok chưa ạ
Đấy mình hoàn toàn là kiểu trang này tải
lại sẽ rất là nhanh thấy không Bởi vì
mình mình sử dụng lấy từ cách ra mà Đấy
mình lấy từ cách ra à không trong này
không không thể hiện được đấy vậy trong
request thì thể hiện mình lấy tư cách ra
đó lấy tư cách
ok chưa
ạ thậm chí thậm chí có hồi trước tôi làm
đó là kiểu xóa cách kiểu này chính xác
không phải xóa cách mà ghi đè hẳn lên
cách luôn Tao ghi hẳn đè gọi lại lên
thang này luôn kiểu kiểu như thế cũng là
một cách nghĩa là xóa cách rồi lưu lại
cách luôn đấy Kiểu
Mình ở đây sa tích gọi se Ừ đúng
đó thì coi như là coi như là kiểu khi
khi mà không phải đợi đến lúc người dùng
vào hẳn cái trang của mình thì mình mới
bắt đầu kích lại nữa mà Kiểu gì nó cũng
sẽ được kích một lần ngay từ lúc mà mình
cập nhật rồi Mình đã lưa lại Kích mới
rồi để người dùng vào sẽ chỉ dùng theo
cách mới thôi đấy ổn không ạ Đấy nẹ hợp
lý mà đúng không Đấy đấy là tôi đã thứ
ra buổi hôm nay nếu mà nói ngắn gọn th
ra hôm qua hôm này đã gần như là xong
rồi đấy tôi dạy cho mấy ông qua về obser
một tí và biết qua v mod event một tí và
cách clear cá như nào rồi m không Ngay
nãy gi có nhanh quá
nay chỉ thế này nhưng Ngoài ra tôi sẽ
nói thêm về hai cái này nữa có hai cái
mà cho thêm ví dụ đi à
Ờ hôm nay là chỉ nói qua thế này thôi
còn về sau tôi tôi tôi bảo kiểu gì tôi
sẽ làm cái cái dự án này từ a đến z nên
là thành ra là kiểu gì kiểu gì em cũng
kiểu các bạn sẽ biết được khi mà mình sử
dụng cách các thứ thứ như nào
nhiều hơn rồi không làm
p nhảy sang l làm C
thấy giờ thất nghiệp á Giờ thất nghiệp
thì em lại ngồi tiếp làm Project trong
lúc mà kiểu đang thất nghiệp thôi chứ em
không thể ngồi chợ Than vãn mình thết
nghiệp được đúng không Mình nên bổ sung
kiến thức để mình tránh bị chọc cái ngày
ngày mà em không bổ sung kiến thức liên
tục em dẫm chân lại chỗ thì bị đào thải
nhan
trong DB có một thằng mới anh sẽ làm sao
để cập nhật lại cách về ạ thì đây đây
cũng là một cái mà tôi có thể nói luôn
cho Mấy ông V khái niệm là cách tác đấy
tôi bằng cách thần kỳ ở đó người dùng
không hề Insert vào trong DB kiểu như
này để mà ngồi xóa cách của thằng này
hoặc là người dùng kiểu dùng sher để tạo
sẵn toàn bộ mấy config này rồi th hành v
cái cách nó mà đang lưu toàn bộ mấy cái
con config cũ này này đúng không Nó đã
kch hết sừ mất toàn bộ cái config này
rồi
thì thì rõ ràng là nó sẽ kiểu không lưu
lưu tậm một tháng mà Thế bây giờ mình
làm gì thì có hai cách đó là ở công ty
tôi thì tôi chơi cái trò đôi khi là kiểu
Miễn Cưỡng ấy mình sẽ đổi con số kiểu
như này tăng lên một số như này để kiểu
mình sẽ coi như là có một cái kch key
mới mình sẽ kiểu toàn bộ những K key cũ
thì coi như là Mình không dùng nữa kiểu
bị kiểu mình thay thế gần như thay thế
một kim mới đấy Đấy đấy là một cách cách
thứ hai đó là mấy ông sẽ có khái niệm
này là mấy ông sẽ có đây nhá Để để tôi
nói lại cho mấy ông dễ hình dung nhá Bây
giờ mình đang có cách key lại theo từng
cái key như này đúng không từng cái key
như này mỗi key này nó đều khác nhau mà
đúng không nên là mình không thể chạy
phòng lặp để biết được toàn bộ tất cả ky
bây giờ đang là gì để mình ngồi xóa theo
từng cái key kiểu này mình forget lần
lượt từng cái ky từng cái ky Làm sao xóa
được vì rõ ràng là mình C không biết
được cụ thể có bao nhiêu cái ki bây giờ
mà đúng không thì một là tôi bảo rồi Một
là ông hẳn đổi hẳn cái ở đây đi thành
một cái số gì đó tôi thường cho số một
rồi về sau càm tăng dần thích khi nà chỉ
cần đổi trong code thế đ coi như là toàn
bộ cái cách cũ sẽ không còn được hiệu
lực nữa đấy là một cách nhưng là cách
đấy nó không hẳn là kiểu tốt lắm Vì mình
phải sửa code rồi để code lên vân vân
thứ hai đó là mình sẽ có khái niệm là
cách ky và theo TC như này không biết
mấy không biết không nhưng là cái tag
này thì nó sẽ có ưu và nhược nó cũng sẽ
có ưu vào Nhược Cái nào cũng có ưu nhược
cả đầu tiên thì ông sẽ tra kch tác của
thằng larel thì nó nó tôi nhớ không lầm
là nó chỉ hỗ trợ cho redit thì phải hỗ
trợ cho một vài cái nữa đây Cái thằng
phiên bản 10 này tài liệu nó không đầy
đủ cho ông xem tài
không support cho Nếu mà kch dạng file
này database hoặc là cái gì gì đó còn
cái khác thì đây ví dụ mem này hoặc là
mem K này hoặc là redit tôi đang dùng ở
công ty thì có thể áp dụng được cái khái
niệm cách này Thực ra là ở công ty ông
phải làm nhiều thì ông mới động đến tôi
vẫn đang nói ở mức độ kiểu đến mức độ
rồi Rồi ví dụ bây giờ tôi đang dùng cáy
cá driver là F như này thì cái tag nó sẽ
báo lỗi nó sẽ không dùng được Tôi cứ ví
dụ cho mấy ông cho mấy ông dễ h Dung đấy
thường là nó sẽ kiểu như này mình sẽ có
một cái cái key config kiểu như
này một một cái ky thì bất kỳ thôi
thường tôi có thể đặt đây là config cũng
được
như
bộ cái toàn bộ những cái config key này
nó sẽ cùng chung một cái T và về sau giả
sử về sau giả sử ông thay vì ông phải
xóa lần lượt từng cái ky một như này
đúng không Ông có thể là
t như này config như này hình như thế
xong rồi FL
như
này nhớ Hình như là như này thì tức là
toàn bộ những cái nào có đính với cái TC
này Trung TC đúng không ạ thì nó sẽ lập
tức bị xóa cùng nhau đấy Đấy cái lợi của
việc cái TC thậm chí thậm chí Giả sử ông
có T một cái config một cái config 1 như
này ông chỉ cần xóa config thôi thì nó
cũng sẽ toàn bộ nh bởi vì TH có cả tag
config mà nó sẽ bay theo cái này nó rất
phù hợp cho ví dụ điển hình ở công ty
tôi nó có chia theo kiểu nhiều user nữa
nên thành ra là bình thường là config
này còn dính theo user ID các thứ thứ
thứ nên cái t này cũng tag theo đây nhá
m hình dung nhá nhiều user đúng không
Mỗi user đấy lại có hàng nghìn sản phẩm
nữa đúng không Thì rõ ràng là ví dụ Giả
sử đây là product chẳng hạn mà đây là
product tại ID chẳng hạn Giả sử thế đấy
thì rõ ràng là Bây giờ tôi chỉ cần theo
một cái là
user xong rồi kèm theo đấy giống như là
đây kèm theo cái thằng đang năng nhật
đấy thì về sau tôi xóa toàn bộ kick key
của cái thằng có user ID là 1 chẳng hạn
đây trong trường hợp thảng Ta đang nhập
và 1 thì toàn bộ những cái product của
thằng của thằng có user là1 nó cũng sẽ
tự động bay theo đấy Nên là cái vụ tác
này nó sẽ rất phù hợp với việc dự án còn
lớn hơn nữa để ông xóa đồng loạt tất cả
kch cùng một lúc theo theo một cái gì đó
theo một cái tác gì
không
sao kiểu gì về sau mấy ông chẳng gặp làm
dự án Giống Như Tôi này Tôi không nghĩ
về sau tôi vào cái dự án to vãi chưởng
để mà ngồi gặp những cái tình huống kiểu
cũng dở khóc dở cười cái thự thứ như này
Ờ Tại sao giử khóc rử cười vì nhiều lúc
phải kiểu phải tự tìm hiểu ấy chứ tài
liệu mấy ông C thấy tài liệu của nó đều
không đấy các thứ xong rồi có ai dạy
mình điều đấy Chẳng ai dạy đ mấy cái đấy
ở trên trường mấy ông nói thẳng như thế
Tôi là người tôi đang chia sẻ mấy ông
Thực tế tôi Tôi thấy có rất nhiều bên
từng dạy larel chẳng ai nhắc với kch kch
tác cả
thật cái này tôi khẳng định thật Bởi vì
tôi tôi cũng xem rất nhiều video các thứ
thứ rồi mà
về cách tác rồi nhá Còn về sau muốn thêm
nhiều ví dụ hay thêm các thứ nữa thì
chắc là làm hơn nhiều sẽ biết đúng không
Anh đây Ờ thứ nhất là mình không nên
ngại nó đã mình kiểu tiếp xúc nó hàng
ngày thôi Hồi trước tôi từng bảo mấy ông
là kiểu Tại sao chúng ta đi du học chúng
ta khả năng học tiếng Anh mình tốt hơn
vì chỉ đơn giản Mình tiếp xúc nó kiểu
kiểu mình không muốn nó vẫn kiểu ập đến
mình ấy xong rồi đặc biệt là mình có nhu
cầu kiểu vẫn muốn giao tiếp với người
xung quanh các thứ mình sẽ tự tự ép bản
thân mình mình đắm chìm trong cái môi
trường đấy nên thành ra là tự tự dưng
mọi thứ mình tốt hơn thôi đấy Kiểu thế
Bây giờ ông muốn cái gì Muốn làm tốt cái
gì ông phải đắm chìm nó trong khoảng
thời gian
tỏ là ông vẫn chưa đến cái bài toán phải
phức tạp phải kiểu cũng nan giải như tôi
rồi nhưng mà cách tác này có nhược điểm
nhá về sau tôi sẽ nói kỹ hơn một cái
nhược điểm này Nó là kiểu một khi ông
khai báo cái tác kiểu như thế là ông Ông
không gọi nó một cách thủ công ông được
ông vẫn phải khai báo tác và đúng thứ tự
tác đấy nó giống như là kiểu cái prefix
ấy Cái tiền tối đằng trước ấy ông khai
báo như thế này một khi ông khai báo lúc
mà kch như thế này đúng không Thì khi
xóa à khi xóa thì không nói xóa thì ông
chỉ xóa theo K key cũng được hoặc xóa
theoo tag được nhưng mà hình như là xóa
theo theo kích kỵ không được phải xóa cụ
thể tác mới được thì phải không nhớ
lắm nhưng mà Lúc gọi đến kiểu lúc mà ghé
nó ra ấy thì ông vẫn phải điền đầy đủ cả
tác và tag vẫn phải đúng theo thứ tự nữa
Nói chung là nó cũng ưu Vừ Nhược nó có
nhiều
lắm Ok Bây giờ sang cái một bài mà bạn
đấy hỏi cái này bài này khá là hay này
Ờ
là bạn ấy muốn làm là kiểu dạng là khi
vào khi mà người dùng tự nhiên bấm vàoo
cái trang kiểu hoặc là kiểu tự động sửa
một cái tham số trang gì đó nó thành
9599 chẳng hạn kiểu lớn hơn cái trang
thực tiễn rất nhiều ấy thì quay trở lại
về trang 1 không hẳn là quay trở về
trang 1 mà vẫn hiển thị ra kết quả nhưng
thực ra là đấy kết quả của trang thứ
nhất thì làm như thế nào thì thì nếu mà
các bạn dùng pinet của larel thì nó tích
hợp sẵn về việc là tự động đếm với cả tự
động phân trang cho các bạn rồi nên
thành ra là các bạn không xử lý cái đoạn
này nó sẽ phức tạp hơn nên các bạn sẽ
không nên dùng cái hàm pinet của larel
nữa đây Tôi ví dụ mấy ông dễ Dung nha
Tôi thử đ k cái này đi tôi khai báo cái
này là ind 1 đi để tránh nhầm sang cái
bạn bảng nào Bây giờ tôi đang có dữ liệu
nhiều
10 người đúng không
Đấy bình
admin
này đây pinet à sự là tôi muốn 5 ngườ 11
chẳng hạn đấy tôi Return admin nh đúng
đúng không Nếu mấy ông biết về khái niệm
pinet của larel rồi nó sẽ trả về đây
mình mặc định sẽ trang đầu tiên này nó
trả về năm người đúng không ạ Và nó sẽ
có tối đa là 10 này và nó có căng nhất
là chỉ hai trang thôi này đúng không Đấy
bây gi Giả sử là hỏi chấm pex bằng 2 thì
nó sẽ mặc định nhảy sang page Thứ hai
này xong rồi lấy năm người còn lại đúng
không ạ Tôi sẽ thử đổi cái
này bây giờ giả sử Giả sử là tôi đổi đây
peg bằng 3 thì chắc chắn là bạn sẽ thấy
là không còn người nào trả về đúng không
Nó nhảy sang p bằng 3 tạm chí là 30 đấy
thì nó sẽ kiểu để sang kiểu trang thứ 30
thế này sai đúng không ạ bởi vì mình
đang dùng cái page mặc định của thằng
mình đang dùng cái p mặc định của thằng
larel tự động lấy th Bây giờ tôi sẽ sửa
lại như
này mặc định là một này tôi sẽ sửa lại
cái đoạn này cái pinet này bản chất là
nó sẽ chạy hai câu truy vấn đây Nếu mấy
ông xem sẽ luôn Chạy thường ha chạy hai
câu truy
vấn
nhỉ m không thấy là nó sẽ luôn là ca này
xong rồi select s form Limit I offset
này vỡ mồm luôn offset này cho bạn nào
chưa biết ấy thì offset này xong rồi
order buy
Này nói lại cho mấy ông một lần nữa nhé
nút
danh sách offset này order by này group
by
thì mấy cái này đều khiến cho câu truy
vấn sẽ nặng hơn Khá là nhiều đấy offset
này càng offset này tức là
sao nĩa là ông phải bỏ qua ông phải
duyệt qu những cái thằng hợp l đã để ông
lấy ra Năm Nghĩa là nghĩa là kiểu ông
phải lấy ra được rất nhiều cái hợp lệ đã
và cái này càng dài thì nói chung là
càng vỡ mồm ví dụ là kiểu set tận 2000
tức là ông Phả duyệt qua 2000 bản ghi
hợp lệ đã rồi ông mới lấy ra năm thằng
đấy Kiểu như thế nên là tuy là Limit 5
thì có vẻ ông chỉ cần lấy năm thằng
nhưng thực là ông phải diệt qua rất
nhiều thằng hợp
lệ thứ thường là nếu mà ông chỉ Limit 5
không thì tức là ông thấy năm thằng hợp
lệ ông lấy luôn rồi thì Thì ông trả về
kết quả rất là sớm đấy nó khác nế thành
ra thường về sau khuyến nghị là không
nên dùng offset nhiều nhưng mà bây giờ
cứ giả sử cứ tính cái bài toán mình dùng
upset đi đây thì ông thấy là như tôi bảo
nó có một câu truy vấn cao sao này để
làm gì Cá sao này code để lấy là Ừ trong
DB ông có bao nhiêu thằng để nó làm cái
phân trang là nó sẽ có bấy nhiêu Trang
tương ứng ấy vừa nãy ông thấy là sẽ có à
đây Tôi sẽ để perpage ở đây sẽ là bằng 5
đúng không Tức là đấy nó có cả offset
các thứ các thứ như
ờ Total
đi đấy để lấy tất cả thằng hợp lệ đúng
không xong ngồi
mà nếu mà giả sử mà offset l lớn hơn
nhân nhân với cái peg mà người đang chọn
lớn hơn kiểu so với Total thì mình quay
trở lại offset bằng 0 và p bằng 0
đó xong rồi Ở đây ông sẽ chỉ cần ghi ở
offset offset
hàm thư viện này pinat
gì Đợi tôi một
tí graap không
pator
Total à đây đây dùng cái thư viện này
mới
đúng
này
này th đâ data này offset này Perfect
hệ này m tội là nó sẽ đổi lại C page
bằng
phải data À
mình đổi đây là
trở lại page 1 ok không ạ Đấy hợp lý
không ạ Đấy tức là sao cái đ bạn này tôi
nói lại nhá bài toán bạn ấy muốn đó
là cái gợi ý đế copilot tôi tắt
tl lâu lắm
của larel mình có thể tự truyền Total và
perp đúng mình có thể tự truyền cái đấy
Ờ Thực ra là tôi chưa tự tự dùng cái thư
cái pinet để truyền mấy tham số đấy Ờ
này không Tôi chưa làm cái vụ kia bao
giờ nhưng mà nhưng mà thằng lel bản chất
nó là gì Nó là cái Framework mà mình có
thể customize rất nhiều thứ nghĩa là một
là mình dùng thư viện này hai dùng thư
viện kia nó vẫn có thể kiểu nó tương
đương Chắc thế
đấy thì tôi thì tôi dùng cái này và và
đấy thì ông vừa thấy thằng chvt nó cũng
gử ý cái này đấy kiểu mình cái bài toán
nói lại bài toán này nhá đó là khi mà
người dùng kiểu truyền một cái page gì
đó một cá Vô Tình Hay là cố ý lớn hơn so
với kiểu tổng số sản phẩm có thật thì
bây giờ mình sẽ quay trở lại thành p 1
kiểu như thế Cái này để lấy ra kiểu tổng
các thứ các thứ đấy Xong rồi lấy như
bình thường thôi đúng không lấy ra dữ
liệu này dùng kiểu cắt bớt nó đi để mình
trả về trong kiểu trang này thì trả về
người này thôi ok không
ạ Đấy trang thứ 30 quay trở lại đúng
không Tôi sẽ gửi code ở đây để cho bạn
đấy tham khảo
nữa câu đấy câu đấy thì ở công ty tôi bị
dính thôi Cái này tức là sao công ty tôi
nó bị cái trường hợp này gần đây bị xảy
ra kiểu tôi bảo rồi công ty tôi dữ liệu
càng càng lớn thì bây giờ mình sẽ cài
phải càng biết tối ưu hơn C tr vần các
thứ bây giờ mấy ông Hình dung là giả sử
Giả sử mấy ông gặp kiểu gì về sau mấy
cũng có thể gặp bài toán này đó là ông
sẽ order buy theo một vài cái nó gợi ý ở
K đoà phải dùng phím tắt như này để mà
mở ra như dùng chuột đấy Đấy giả sử ông
gặp những cái bài toán
kểu Ông cần lấy cái thằng này lên trước
cái thằng này lên trước các thứ các thứ
thì ông thường thường có thể ghi kiểu
này order byy ví dụ là
email chẳng hạn IC lên trước như
này cái này mặc định order bu nó I nên
nó cảnh báo tôi là có thể xóa xóa đi
được đấy Ok tiếp theo tôi order buy một
cái gì đó nữa cái update như này chẳng
hạn
dsc Một ông viết kiểu này hay ông ghi
kiểu này cũng được này sẽ bỏ đi
không phải order by rất nhiều thứ như
này
thì như vừa nãy tôi có nốt mấy ông thấy
không ạ order by cũng khiến cho câu try
vần nó bị nặng hơn ở công ty tôi vừa gặp
cái vụ này xong đó là kiểu nếu mà ông
lấy hết dữ liệu ra kể cả ông có que thêm
ở đây nhá Nhưng mấy ông không hề Limit
nó mấy ông Limit nó ở đây như này ví dụ
10 hay là cái gì Limit một cái gì đó thì
mình mới cần mình cần phải giữ lại order
by này bởi vì bởi vì kiểu Sắp xếp xong
thì tao chỉ lấy 10 thôi mà đúng không
Thì nó còn hợp lý còn bây giờ là ông
không hề Limit nó là tức là kiểu gì ông
sẽ lấy hết ra ông có thể thêm một đống
que các thứ thứ ở trên như này gì đó
nhưng mà bản chất là ông vẫn lấy hết ra
rồi Ông sắp xếp các thử à Ông lấy ra kèm
theo việc sắp xếp nó khiến nó rất là
nặng cho database ở đây nó sẽ bài toán
là ông muốn làm nặng nặng database không
Hay là
ông ông muốn làm nặng databas thay vì
ông kiểu nặng hệ thống xử lý code thì
ông xử lý bằng code hay ông xử lý bằng
truy vấn tùy theo Tôi thường là mình vẫn
không nên làm nặng khu truy vấn khu truy
vấn mình luôn nên nhẹ và mình sẽ xử lý
lại cái này bằng code Tức là sao tôi sẽ
vứt hết đống này đang sau như th này cái
này sẽ dùng hàm short by này SH by SH by
hay cái gì đó hình như là
thế thằng Collection nó sẽ có những
cái hàm để mà mình mình sắp xếp lại
đây s
này
nó
ồ Tôi không chắc về việc là nó sẽ ưu
tiên thằng này hay là nó lại sắp xếp lại
theo phát nữa sắp xếp lại theo phát nữa
Tôi không chắc về vụ đấy nhá Nhưng mà ý
tôi là
ông ông làm kiểu
gì Nói chung là Đấy cách của mình đúng
không Mình sẽ xử lý sắp xếp lại bằng
code chứ mình không nên sắp Khi mà mình
một khi đ lấy hết dữ liệu ra thì mình
không nên sắp xếp order buy ở trong câu
truy vấn hạn chế thực ra là tôi đang vẫn
đang nói là bài toán phải dữ liệu lớn
giống như cái bảng của tôi sáng nay bị
thì là bảng đấy có gần 200 triệu bản ghi
mà ông order b thì ông chỉ có chết thôi
Cho dù kể cả câu que của ông có kiểu nó
đỡ hơn phần nào nhưng mà nó vẫn hạn chế
ông hiểu nên là Nên là nếu mà có thể thì
mình nên lấy dữ liệu ra đã để nó không
bị kiểu treo hệ thống treo database thì
không được đúng không À và ông sẽ sắp
xếp lại bằng trong
nhúng vào mod cũng ok anh nhỉ Ừ nếu mà
em xử lý nhiều thì em nên viết vào trong
chat là hợp lý thức ra
là mình anh vẫn đang kiểu Demo ở
controller thực ra mình không nên xử lý
các thứ ở controller mà đúng không mình
xử lý ở chỗ
khác hôm nào có thời gian nói qua về Red
full api Thực ra là mình đang làm rất
nhiều với api đấy r full api đấy Chẳng
qua các bạn không nhận ra rồi tôi không
Tôi cũng làm thường xuyên đ tôi không
gọi là hiểu rõ bản chất nó
lắm
đấy mấy ông hiểu không ạ nghĩa là đấy
Nói chung là tôi vừa thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ
kiểu gặp những cái vấn đề gì đó thực
tiễn cho tôi sẽ kiểu đ là khuyên mấy ông
hy vọng có một ngày mấy
ông mắc phải thì kiểu có tiền bối đi
trước người ta nói cho đúng
ạ Chắc là về sau nhá Không biết về sau
sẽ thích hợp cái
gì
rồi bả Sao tự nhiên mình nói cũng bắt
đầu khản giọng dần rồi Ờ tôi cũng trả
lời được khá nhiều cái rồi Nếu mà Mấy
ông có thắc mắc gì thì mấy ông tạo THT ở
đấy thớt ở trong này chúng ta thảo luận
các thử thử nhá
Ờ và đấy tôi tạo cái thớt để trả lại trả
bài mấy ông vào đây để trả bài nhá Sang
tuần tôi hy vọng là có vài ông trà bài
trong này chúng ta cũng nhìn cùng nhau
rồi cùng chữa các thử cho
mình cứ tạm nghỉ rồi hết toàn bộ những
cái rồi thì đang dùng thì cũng là qua về
pp stor rồi còn những tiện í khác ở trên
máy thì chắc là khi mấy ông thấy hỏi thì
tôi trả lời tôi cũng không cài nhiều